(epic orchestral music)
- I'm team Xbox, PS4, and to
a lesser extent, Nintendo.
- I'm Terry Crews, and
I'm team PC Master Race.
- So Terry, are you a gamer?
- Yes I am.
- So, what type of games do you play?
(laughs)
- I feel like this is a setup.
- Let me tell you about one
game in particular. Madden.
You play Madden with a joystick,
looking dead in the eye of the
person that you're beating,
right on the same couch.
- That's great, but
you know, the thing is,
I played in the NFL, Ned.
(laughs)
Madden on console is a
cheap, cheap imitation, dude.
Using the console, you've got your little,
all your little cheat codes,
and all your little moves
and the whole thing.
It's just always you and
a buddy, and beers, and
you're knocking over stuff.
Let me tell you something,
you don't get anywhere near my PC.
- I got three words for you Terry.
- Okay
- Super Smash Brothers. Ever head of it?
- Okay, but you know
what's bad? I mean, again,
you've been living a JC Penney life.
It's time to step up to Tom Ford.
The framerates,
you have to have your
cable management together!
If your cable management is
all jacked up, you jacked up!
- I don't need to talk
about wire management,
'cause I've got the wireless controller.
You can play in front of the
tv, you can play on the couch.
How many times are you going
to take a PC to your couch?
- No
- Never
- Because you have a nice,
beautiful desk setup.
You have three monitors.
- Yeah
- The console man,
- You're right, one screen isn't enough.
Unless there's an actual human,
on the couch playing there with you.
- Oh
- When are you gonna do that with a PC?
- But, it's not that good.
It's just not that good.
It's not the experience
- But it just works,
Terry. I just plug it in,
I pay $60 a year, and it just works.
- Oh man, you know what,
but your life isn't.
Your life's not working.
- What evidence have I
given you thus far that
my life's not working?
- By your socks. I can see
your sock. The polka dot socks.
- These are great socks!
- His whole life is a sham!
- That's not true.
- He's settled for much less.
Show me how this works.
Go show me.
- You really set me up
for that one, didn't you?
- Yeah I did. Go show me how it works.
- So first of all, you
click the center screen.
- Nah, I didn't mean that.
- Mhmm?
- I said get up,
and show me.
(loud impact sound)
- PC's are trash, Terry Crews.
PC's are trash. Go Steam
account that together.
- Turn that off. I don't
anybody to witness this.
- You heard him, turn the cameras off.
- We don't need any witnesses,
what's about to happen.
(epic orchestral music)
(laughter)